two suspected gunmen have been shot dead
by police after they opened fire at an
anti-islam art exhibit near Dallas in
Texas he reportedly fired at a police
officer outside an exhibition featuring
depictions of the Prophet Mohammed in
the suburb of Garland now it isn't
immediately clear if the shooting was
directly related to the event itself
while joining me on the line now is kim
everett of the Garlin News Kim just shed
some light on this event what is the
latest so far what I've been able to
find out is at about 7:30
Dallas time again man drove up to the
interests are very near the entrance of
the Curtis Culwell Center which is a
Garland Independent School District
building where the event was being held
they shot a GI SD a Garland Independent
School District peace officer there and
from what I've been told the SWAT team
from the garland Police Department heard
the shots and were able to get out of
the building in time to catch them and
stop them from going into the building
where the event was now there had been a
lot of concern before this event it's it
was held in a school district that what
are the police saying the police have
not had a press conference yet so far
all they have done to my knowledge is to
take the people that were event
attending the event to nearby safer
areas and they will be questioning all
of them of course they didn't let them
go out to their own cars and leave for
two reasons the first being their safety
and the other that they need to be
questioned now we've got shots here
armed police inside the building itself
was there a lot of confusion at the time
no actually
heard that it was all calm I heard an
interview with a lady named Katrina
Pierson who actually is the person who
started the tea party in the Garland
area and she was there and she said that
everything was fairly calmed that this
one team after they had shot the man
outside went back inside it went up to
the stage and to tell them that they
were going to be evacuating and and then
they just proceeded to do that how many
people said you know they can't be
surprised to this holding an anti-islam
cartoon exhibit particularly with people
such as Pam Geller and get builders in
it in attendance well there has been a
lot of controversy about that of course
back in January there was a has-been
stand with Islam I think events held in
the same building and there were a lot
of protesters outside that building
during the entire event and people in
Berlin were really kind of afraid that
something like this would happen bend
and of course we were very relieved when
it went on smoothly but then because
that venue had been used for that event
I believe that's what made Pamela Geller
want to use the venue for this event as
well no you used I had I had been
watching all afternoon checking on it to
find out if there were any protesters
there anything and there were not no one
had gathered to protest and it seemed
like it was all going to go smoothly
until this happened it's been described
as being it within a school district
does that mean that there were a number
of schools around because the area as we
can see now on our screen with the
lights seems very quiet
obviously in lockdown yes it is
I think they said that there was a half
mile perimeter around the entire area
but there is a run high school just next
door to the event center where where the
event was when we say school district
that just means that every school in
violence belongs to or is part of the
Garland Independent School District
it is a rather large time and there are
seven high schools so the the event
center just coincidentally happens to be
next to one of those high school okay so
we understand now that they are
searching there have been reports from
city officials garland officials that
there have been reports of an incendiary
device within a car any update on that
the only thing I know about that is that
they have them robots checking I there
has not been confirmation that there is
any kind of explosive device I'm just
hearing that they want to be absolutely
certain so the they have the robots
they're checking the car it's the few
more questions just to clarify initially
about a hundred people have been held
safely it was stressed within the center
have they all been evacuated now yes my
understanding is that they are all out
now okay could you tell us a little bit
more about Pam Geller please well I only
know what what I've been able to read
online to be perfectly honest because I
just started to research it when we
found out that that this event was going
to be held in Garland I have heard
though that I you know obviously I
haven't spoken to her but I have heard
that she wanted to use this venue
because it was the same one that was
used for the stand stand with Islam
event I've also you know from everything
I read she says that every all her
are her effort to preserve freedom of
speech in America that's really all I
know about her Tim